I'm still rolling along through the
state of Hesse the scenery is great but
there are Hills hills and more hills
after a short ride I'm now in the south
of Darmstadt still I'm starting to get
tired of switching legs every 10 times
it's so but I'm getting closer to my
goal I am 57 days and a respectable 1673
kilometers behind me and on my way I
discovered the famous Frankenstein
castle spooky in 1818 when she was just
21 British writer Mary Shelley's famous
novel Frankenstein was published in it
dr. Frankenstein creates a monster that
soon develops its own life people say
it's no accident that the castle here
bears the same name as the doctor I
talked to some of the visitors was the
Frankenstein monster really created here
well I can't tell you that but the
castle was built on Frankenstein Hill
well a scientist lived here and he tried
out experiments on dead people I think
just couldn't do it outside certainly
possible when you're up around the
castle there are these really scary
spots so it's not unthinkable that this
is the place that's the sea of Oz ya s
is here
so who knows as I tour the castle I
imagine the famous dr. Frankenstein in
the dungeon at full moon putting the
final touches on the monster
okay I can imagine a lot but only an
expert can know Mateus Brewer has leased
the castle was there ever an operating
table down in the dungeon here an
operating table I don't know it was 200
years ago but yuan combo dipper from
Frankenstein certainly dissected
cadavers here because he was a scientist
an alchemist and a famous man in any
case the castle was first mentioned in a
document in 1252 and the noble
Frankenstein family lived here without
monsters
Germany has lots of castles and palaces
25,000 of them one breaks all tourist
records neuschwanstein in bavaria with
more than 1.4 million visitors a year
but there are more records for cows in
his europe's longest castle complex at
just over a kilometer and the world's
longest sand castle was built in 2011 on
the baltic sea island of rügen what's
spookiest about this castle nowadays
there are always new key moments
recently I went into the tower at 8:30
at night it was dark and under the tower
is a room that used to be a cellar a
dungeon like vault with no stairs you
can only get there through a hole a five
meter drop and I heard shrieks and there
was no one in the castle and to this day
I don't know what that was okay that
does sound spooky but from the castle
wall there's a fantastic view and nary a
shriek far and wide after the past few
tiring weeks I find it peaceful and
relaxing nevertheless I will give the
castle a last chance to scare someone
dressed up as Frankenstein's monster I
can help it regain its authenticity
I seem to have scared away the last
tourists time to move on undaunted by
the legends surrounding the castle and
using a scooter isn't spooky at all
you